[Music]
Whitney Carson's new partner Chris
Master has two left feet rehearsal but
Billy Penn we must say is very easy on
the eye not the greatest of dancers I
would say from a scale from one to ten
I'm probably in the mid to range I was
like what was your go-to dance like just
end the club or you know whatever and he
goes like this job hot loser during the
Olympics the six-foot one silver
medalist is still trying to find his
footing in the ballroom I see what
Whitney does and I'm like why can't I do
that and then I'll try a thousand times
and I'm like still can't do that let's
do that again so I have to get a spray
tan
in this okay I don't know this is news
to me
but you do have to wear like stones
everywhere and tight clothes tight
clothes no problems high clothes I'm
really good at the all athlete season
it's just four weeks long so Whitney
strategy to stand out from the other
nine contestants involves Chris getting
shirtless yeah we may or may not be
doing it the first dance you know just
have to watch but sorry ladies the 29
year old is a taken man I'm off the
market America and yeah you can still
vote me like we're still gonna have a
lot of fun you can still have posters of
him and your body will still interact
like I still have a good time with
everybody like but that's something
that's out of that that I did not mean
it that way
I promise like huh
[Music]
[Applause]